[Music]
down into the victim hello my name is
Matthew Steiner Matt Steiner is a senior
crime scene analyst and veteran
investigator of over 22 years today I'm
breaking down crime scene clips from
movies and TV again decomposing body
solids in the lamps what else do sue
story
well she's not local her ears are
pierced three times in nurse' Oh glitter
nail polish oh I did like is yeah she
starts describing the injuries and she
does a really good job of describing a
contact gunshot wound
she then describes a star shape or
stellite pattern
shape contact entrance wound which is
indicative of a contact wound
they also say they're gonna flip the
body over to make it easier to
fingerprint should be easier to print if
we turn it over that's true also it is
easier to fingerprint the body if you
turn the body over if you look at the
way they showed the arms they show
what's called marbling and then that's
like part of the decomposition process
where the hemoglobin will break down
inside the blood vessels but if we have
arms like she had where it was in that
stage of marbling we would also see more
advanced decomposition in her face in
this scene we see that Clarice notices
something that was in the photograph
that they didn't see normally she's got
something in her throat you're taking a
close to photograph of something you'll
notice more detail on that photograph
than you did with your naked eye so this
does happen through you city smells you
would never see them with anything
underneath their nose like that right
it's better just to get used to the
smell like you'll get used to it and you
just won't forget about the smell but if
you try to mask it occasionally you'll
get a whiff that's gonna break through
that vapor rub and it's gonna be worse
transient evidence Sherlock
in this scene he notices very important
details about the transient nature of
evidence things that aren't permanent
Aries are wet
Aries are dry so you get to the crime
scene there's a glass on the counter and
it's got ice in it it's not gonna stay
you know in that form it's gonna melt
eventually there's no other way to
capture that then to note that and these
are all types of transient evidence that
we could encounter at a crime scene and
that's what Sherlock Holmes is all about
it was all about the devil being in the
details Arthur Conan Doyle the author of
Sherlock was himself a doctor and a
scientist and was a great influence on
the field of forensic science most
notably he influenced Edmond Locard
famous French scientist who's been
considered the father of forensic
science he came up with this exchange
principle that there is a contact
between two things two objects a person
and a scene seeing in a person as
something is transferred there and this
is the basic founding principle of
forensic science we're looking for
what's left behind and this is all
inspired by Arthur Conan Doyle bite mark
analysis NCIS here's tuckies muscle
tissue scan a little 3d magic for
clarity and I give you the killer's
incisors yeah this is just pure
television not reality you wouldn't
realize what you're looking at unless
you're trained in that sort of software
it's not gonna come up with these fun
little green boxes like this back at
2090 and National Academy of Sciences
came out with a report about the
validity of certain fields in forensic
science and one of the fields that they
questioned was bite mark analysis these
matching are like a hundred thousand to
one your skin it's not like the molding
stuff that you would see at a dentist
you know it's not gonna believe a
perfect impression it's uneven as many
reasons why you you wouldn't be able to
leave a perfect impression where you'd
match them to someone's teeth like we
see in this clip there have been many
cases where you would have two different
experts two different odontologists that
don't agree on the same case so that's
why this evidence has been questioned as
of late well that's great chipper robot
cop Robocop
so yeah this is like really cool
technology no longer in the
not-too-distant future obviously it's
not gonna be like this this is a movie
but we do use some of those types of
technologies that we see there so he's
doing some sort of scanning at crime
scenes we use a 3d laser scanner and
that's a great way to document the scene
the geometry of the scene as well as
taking imaging of the scene too later on
have a first-person perspective of what
that scene look like and it's invaluable
for reconstructions you could bring in a
jury into that scene to show what it
looked like first person virtually and
just think about for training you know
you have all these scenes that now are
captured and you can bring other people
that weren't there to show them you know
how we investigated the scene he then
uses the camera imaging of surveillance
cameras to do photogrammetry so the
positions of the cameras are solved and
then we could figure out the position
where that car was originally so he then
takes those two types of evidence pieces
them together and has his reconstruction
haunted house crime-scene Criminal Minds
the unsub might have sustained injuries
we should check local hospitals just in
case is the unsub headed disarmed Kim
before he could attack her that would
have been a lot more work for him yeah
the only obstacle this time would have
been her husband Brad but the ends I've
got the jump on him out in the hallway
the unsub's ability say unsub a lot in
this clip on something on something else
ever did the unsub's evolving unsub I
think is unknown subject or unidentified
subject in the 22 years of working crime
scenes I've never heard another
detective use that term the unsub's guys
the perfect unsub so you know eventually
they take a break from saying unsub and
they notice these piles of salt inside
of a crime scene so sometimes we do see
evidence of people supernatural beliefs
and superstitions at a crime scene I've
seen piles of salt had a case where they
had a cauldron with a human skull with
liquid mercury on it whether a crime
scene is haunted I've never seen that
investigated over 2,000 crime scenes
most scenes where someone died of a
violent nature and it yet to see a ghost
or an apparition crime scene
contamination No Country for Old Men I
know this name all's I don't understand
whether riding a horse to the crime
scene it's the same tire tread coming
back it's going made about the same time
being at the distance from the height of
a horse to look down you could be
missing things it could be destroying
serology it could be destroying footwear
impressions could be stepping on bullets
and casings and who knows what else
Mexican Browns Oh Tommy Lee should be
wearing gloves we don't want to touch
evidence with bare hands
especially not narcotic but you don't
believe it no stab wound analysis
bluebloods
an attacker who's 5 foot 10 would angle
more down into the victims sternum the
angle on Miss Robbins is more level
indicating an attacker who's no more
than five foot six it's just complete
horseshit by the way so
the job of the forensic pathologist is
the document wound paths but they would
never postulate the height of the
attacker five foot six you could be
crouched she could be standing tall you
could be on the ground you know which
would all affect the way that your
wounded whether it's going straight in
or at an angle even her like her
demonstration on Donnie Wahlberg she
shows her even herself stabbing downward
and stabbing straight it you know the
person could jump up and attack them
there's so many variables here that they
would never estimate a killers height at
the depth of penetration is markedly
less than typically associated with the
upper-body strength of a male so a
shorter woman this is completely wrong
skin is what offers the greatest
resistance not the tissue itself once
you breach the skin it's relatively easy
to go to a further depth of pathologists
would never say that it was a woman over
a man they mostly are concerned with the
cause and manner of death fingerprinting
the return of the pink panther I mean
obviously this is a comedy but this is
obviously not the right way to do it
either
besides the excessive amount of
fingerprint powder and then his
magnifying glass failing and falling
onto the events and then following onto
the evidence introducing DNA to the
evidence these are all wrong things he
pulled himself across the floor of
course he would need a very slippery
floor to do that
therefore the wax duex I have to admit I
have fallen down at a crime scene
on several occasions my co-workers have
fallen down at crime scenes even though
he's not wearing personal protective
equipment we do and the bottoms of the
feet on those personal protective
equipment those Tyvek suits can be very
slick and you can't fall down are you
all right all right examining the wigs
smelling of evidence the closer guy
drinks passes out in the hot tub his
body temperature rises his liver
explodes his robe soaking wet she's
smelling evidence which is a good way to
document the transient type of evidence
we'll be there chlorine so that smell
may be gone hours later
days later what I don't like is that you
smashed her face into the towel
that's a contamination issue and it's
gross I mean you don't know what's on
that towel to begin with it you know it
could have been feces that could have
been urine and now that's all over your
face lieutenant Flynn could you do the
honors the mower please wait someone and
you just took DNA from the towel well
that could have been on a towel and then
put that onto the toupee so - no nose
right there
I need this hair II threw aside beef in
about two shakes of a lamb's tail
shaking of that you pay is a no-no there
could be DNA on there and by you shaking
it you could be losing that and plus
you're contaminating somebody else by
I'm getting hit in the face but whatever
it was on that toupee thank you thank
you death investigation Sherlock suicide
is pretty common among city boys we
don't know that it was suicide come on
the door was locked from the inside you
had to climb down the balcony
so anything we actually have a homicide
that's being posed as a suicide you've
got a solution that you like but you're
choosing to ignore anything you see that
doesn't comply with it I like what
Sherlock says here that you're just
taking some of the evidence and basing
your theories on that and ignoring all
the other evidence so in this case he
uses deductive reasoning to come up with
the handedness of our victim like the
rooms on the right side of his head and
thank who was left-handed was quite a
bit of contortion left-handed normally
the easiest way to figure out the
handedness of somebody is just asking
you know the family friends co-workers
to somebody they would know whether he
was left-handed or not coffee table on
the left-hand side coffee mug handle
pointing to the left we do I then want
to look at other evidence that could be
supporting that it's a homicide not a
suicide some people are ambidextrous
some people have crossed dominance well
they prefer to do certain actions with
certain hands
there are plenty people that are
left-handed that shoot guns with their
right hand
he's also ignoring that fact you're
finally asking the right questions
tasting evidence bones bones bones get
it
what are you doing yeah yuck you would
never want to put evidence in your mouth
so you don't lick bones who licks bones
it's been in Russia human forensic
anthropologist just by looking at it we
know that it was human by its shape and
by knowing what that looks like versus a
dog bone versus a chicken bone burned
body CSI Miami traces of hydrocarbon we
use the mini ready to detect the
hydrocarbons he left behind and find his
point of order
it's great idea we see them using a mini
Ray which is a version of the multi ray
which is a BOC detector to detect
hydrocarbons she's kind of waving it
around like a divining rod and that's
not the proper way to use it first off
you want to be closer to the surface
that you suspect the accelerant to be on
so she have to be lower to the ground to
really detect anything significant this
is definitely our point of origin I
think it was an excuse for them to use
some cool tech like the mini ray but I
mean a real-life crime scene you would
do a search and in that search you would
have found a large burn pool in the
parking lot illegal DNA collection
Luther
so that's a really interesting yet very
illegal way to get DNA from somebody the
fruits of the poisonous tree refers to
evidence that's obtained illegally the
metaphor is that the tree being the
source of the evidence if that is
tainted anything that comes from the way
that you collect that evidence is also
tainted to the fruit most commonly we'll
get DNA from somebody through consent or
a court order another way to get DNA
from somebody is through what's called
an abandonment sample this is where
investigators will collect things that
are discarded by a suspect that could be
a can of soda a cigarette butt that was
willingly left behind sometimes this
takes a lot of work sometimes
investigators have to follow somebody
around for weeks at a time waiting for
them to spin on the sidewalk or to drop
some trash even though it may be
tempting to get evidence in this way
you don't want to lose that case by
doing something stupid like collecting
evidence in a legal way know exactly
what that feels like
returning to the crime scene red dragon
[Music]
where's the dog no one heard barking
there's nothing about in the case file
[Music]
so what I really like about this is that
yeah they show a crime scene that's
properly safeguarded even on the door
they have a door seal that door has a
broken window that they have put a piece
of cardboard and secured that cardboard
with evidence tape this is what you
would want to see when you went to a
crime scene especially we went back we
want to make sure you're the one that's
breaking the seal that door to you know
make sure that there's continuity inside
the crime scene it that if you collect
evidence now that it wasn't placed by
somebody else coming into the scene
afterwards the one little misstep I see
is that nothing is processed for
fingerprints
that whole path of him going up the
stairs those walls would be covered with
fingerprint powder
[Music]
we see here is you know the set
designers attempt at creating arterial
spatter on the wall those are those
arcing patterns that we see they don't
look very realistic but the mechanism
that's used to create them is very
difficult to replicate so I understand
you know why it doesn't look perfect
other patterns that they got right
though was those drag marks and that's
definitely important types of blessing
patterns that we want to look at we want
to look at the direction in which those
drag patterns are going and we could
tell that by the feathering of the blood
as it's moving in a certain direction
drag the bodies into the master bedroom
we see another pattern that's
interesting to me on the mirror didn't
look like they sampled those bloodstains
once it's dried you know we're gonna
take a swab of some sort we're gonna
hydrate that swab with distilled water
and then we're gonna swab as much as
that stain as possible
or at least a section of it you would
see lines through it where the person
was sampling I didn't see that here it's
possible that it did it but I don't
think the children were still in their
beds when they were shot which might
indicate that he used a silencer that's
a possibility but but one of many
possibilities we see a lot of times in
TVs and movies people using silencers
but in real life we rarely see them this
is crime scene theory Fargo you
shouldn't drink coffee at a crime scene
or any sort of beverage really geez
here's the second one the biggest
contaminant to a crime scene is the
people that go into it the investigators
themselves get that's a defensive wound
at a scene we may act things out the
biomechanics of the way things could
happen like that or bad or like this we
got a shooting these folks drive by
there's a high-speed pursuit ends here
and then this execution type deal she
definitely came to conclusions way too
quickly
yeah has a lot to take in and she didn't
go look at the other victim that was
down the road that the trooper let's go
take a look at that trooper to figure
out sequencing you'd have to look at
everything but a more detailed look at
it before you just come to a snap
decision see something down there chief
no I just think I'm gonna Verve suspect
line up rook
99 I heard him he was singing along to
the music at the bar do you remember
what he was singing I think it was that
song I want it that way
Backstreet Boys I'm familiar number one
could you please sing the opening - I
want it that way
ok you are my father
forensic phonetic analysis usually is
involved with recorded audio evidence
not so much this you know in person
audio lineup tell me why most experts
will say that you can't uniquely
identify someone by their boys this is
obviously for comedy purposes
number five killed my brother oh my god
I forgot about that part fingerprint
database person of interest wow what the
computer is looking at is different
points of identification Wow so if you
look at your fingerprints anywhere that
your lines your fingerprint come apart
they come together create Islands they
start they stop these are all points of
identification your guys prints were
found in half a dozen crime scenes over
the years and when they do have a match
you know it could be a match to several
different possibilities you go down that
coda and then the investigator themself
has to go through each one and include
or exclude who it actually is and then
finally any results any sort of
identification that's made has to be
verified by someone else is independent
and objective in the case crime-scene
cleanup The Simpsons I've never seen an
angel dust for gun-swap goes so wrong
normally it would be more than one
person that it would be tasked to clean
up the scene all right get some paper
towels and to clean up and dispose of
that biohazard waste you need multiple
people as well let me start with this
filthy crime scene tape
eating at a crime scene and CIS are you
eating the crime scene okay first off
mom I'm wearing gloves takes people
guide you there just in the beginning of
this crime scene investigation he may be
sitting at a desk that the suspect was
at maybe there was important evidence
that's there no I'm wearing gloves but
even if he's wearing gloves and that's
weird to be eating food with wearing
gloves like that I guess you could do it
no but you still have that you know
whatever that grease is from this
petition and they're delicious and
you're transferring it to that area that
you're working in give me some and again
that could be an important area that
they find out later on that the suspect
was that don't leave the whole vibe um
we found something too many people in a
crime scene
hot buzz
there are way too many people inside
this crime scene I know you wouldn't
answer your phone inside the scene you
don't want things from your phone to get
into the scene and you don't want things
from the scene to get into your phone
necklace what do you want well I have
something important to tell you and I
didn't want to do it over the phone
this clip shows some good things and
some bad things that are wearing not
only just the type of suit and gloves
that masks on they have eye protection
on then simon pegg goes to see and he's
not wearing anything they probably would
not have allowed simon pegg to enter
that scene without wearing personal
protective equipment you need I've been
transferred I'm moving away for a while
well not Jeanine taking money from a
crime scene training day that's a
quarter million dollars you're holding
right there in your hands buy your wife
a minivan with that put the kids through
college give me that back you know we
only checks our cash so yeah LAPD on
them right Matt you don't want a piece
of this huh all right right I'm with
Ethan Hawke on this one it's not worth
it yeah it's not worth throwing your
life away
no one wants to go to jail no large sums
of money found at a crime scene it has
to be documented and usually it's in the
presence of some sort of supervision
first time you're not comfortable I'll
hold it for you in police departments
they're usually some sort of entity that
does internal investigations and part of
that is doing integrity testing as well
don't touch a thing
he's testing a theory Ace Ventura pet
detective may I tell you what I think
happened all righty then
roger podacter went out after work he
had a few drinks and he came home but he
wasn't alone so there's way too many
people here when you establish a crime
scene you maintain what's called a crime
scene log and it tracks everyone that
comes into that scene everyone that
leaves that scene and unfortunately that
includes pet detectives this woman is
roger podacter 'he's neighbors she lives
across the hall she said she heard a
scream
is that right man right and even if it
was a witness that was inside the scene
it's time we want to remove them from
the scene you said you had to open the
balcony door when you keyed into the
room he wouldn't brought to a police
facility for an interview what's the
point Ventura
in this case the neighbor hear something
and then East comes up with a theory as
to the position of the door during the
time of the events no way that neighbor
could have heard the doctor scream on
the way down with that door shut and
then relating that to someone coming
afterwards and saying that the door was
shut
disapproving that it was a suicide the
scream she heard came from inside this
apartment before he was thrown over the
balcony and the murderer closed the door
before he left but we will record that
and it would probably be a little more
professional than singing and screaming
and hoping at door opening yes
for instance no-win River why would a
teenage girl be out here only know what
the tracks say okay well that's all we
got ya know so you see this one she
other toast or no Footwear is probably
one of the most overlooked types of
evidence at a crime scene the
interpretation that jeremy renner does
here is he's looking at first off the
orientation of the shoe where
impressions and he's interpreting first
off the direction that's very simple by
looking at the way that the heel and toe
are oriented and then he's interpreting
which sometimes could be a little more
harder to discern is that she was
running the foot is much deeper than the
back she's running this is kind of
questionable you know to say that
exactly she was running if you're
carrying something that also would
change the depth of your shoe our
impressions and I also could do with the
density of the snow she ran until she
dropped here to the pool blood but you'd
have to look at multiple shoe
impressions first off it's got to be
photographed
we'd coat it with several layers of snow
print wax
this is an aerosolized wax that will
spray on snow that has impressions on it
and normally that even gives us some
more contrast so we may photograph it
again and then the last step is to cast
it by using some sort of impression
casting material dead body in a freezer
good fella's
[Music]
yeah I've had cases where you know it
was mafia hits it's funny how sometimes
it's like cliche you know the victim was
wearing a tracksuit and you know looks
just exactly like he would on TV he was
frozen so stiff it took them two days to
thaw and melt for the autopsy Frankie
Carbone would take two days to thaw out
before autopsy is it unusual it may even
take up to a week depending on how they
thaw out the body we've also seen
criminals that use this to hide the time
of death so one that I could think of
offhand is richard kuklinski who is
nicknamed The Iceman killer he would
store his dead bodies the people that he
killed that he murdered that he
assassinated in an industrial freezer
and then dumped them at later periods of
time in different areas to confuse the
police at a time of death so having
bodies frozen solid isn't rare actually
it happens quite a bit in the colder
States here in America another hair
analysis seen Castle long blonde hair
this could have come from one of the
women at the bachelorette party that's
what I thought until I had it tested
came back positive for testosterone and
anabolic steroids your blondie is a man
couldn't it be that it's a woman that's
taking testosterone and anabolic
steroids and that would show up in her
hair at one time they would analyze hair
and it would say gender they would say
race they would even match a hair from a
crime scene to a suspect
today they no longer do those things
they'll take a hair and they'll analyze
it for suitability for DNA other things
they could tell about a hair is whether
it's chemically treated whether it was
burned how it was removed a stage of
development that hair is in the somatic
origin of the hair whether it came from
your head from your eyelash from your
pubic hair those are things that can
tell but not whether it's a man or a
woman
so the public's perception on what
forensics is and what crime-scene
investigators do is often built on these
types of shows this attention that the
public now has is fascination that they
have with true crime and with crime
scene type of shows is good because when
people go in to testify to cases they
have a touchstone they have to know
something about this sort of evidence
because they like these shows I don't
expect how I would to always get it
right but it's interesting to see it
when they get it wrong if you're
enjoying technique critiques subscribe
to Wired